donald trump el vicepresidente mike
pence el candidato demócrata joe biden y
su fórmula vicepresidencial kamala
harris todos de regreso a la campaña a
11 días de las elecciones ya no habrá
más debates y la atención de los
contrincantes se centra en las calles y
los actos de campaña
trump regresa a florida a un estado en
el que ganó en 2016 pero que según las
encuestas en esta ocasión está cabeza a
cabeza con bailén el aspirante demócrata
estaría ganando entre la tercera edad un
grupo en el que el magnate arrasó hace
cuatro años pero que ahora le estaría
dando la espalda en medio de la pandemia
mañana voy a votar de manera anticipada
en florida pueden creer que viene a
votar vine aquí a votar en realidad vine
hasta aquí a visitar vi la vis y mañana
en la mañana voy a votar a favor del
rangers by den se encuentran de la
huerta su estado natal y un bastión
demócrata el candidato se alejó de las
calles varios días en la previa del
debate preparando esa ciudad contra
trump ahora vuelve al atril y con un
fuerte ataque contra el presidente por
su manejo de la pandemia
con siéndolo llevamos más de ocho meses
en esta crisis y el presidente aún no
tiene un plan
se rindió los abandonó abandonó a su
familia abandonó a eeuu y américa
y con trump en florida y biden en
delaware cada uno mueve sus fichas para
ganar hasta el último voto posible este
viernes kamala harris la candidata
vicepresidencial demócrata estuvo en
georgia otro estado indeciso cuya
diversidad política está en auge
mientras que mike pence el
vicepresidente del trump viajó hasta
ohio un estado en el que los
republicanos siempre han ganado cuando
han llegado al poder